and um
it is a
great pleasure i'm really grateful to be
here
and um
i have known peter for about 10 years
now
and um like many of you were saying
yesterday evening uh peter and nancy's
hospitality and kindness it's
never really just
for an individual it extends to your
family as well so every time i bring
kids to berkeley for example we have to
take them to see peter and nancy so i
found this picture that's my daughter
right there having free reign in peter
and nancy's living room and
and i remember that i was kind of trying
to control her movements a little and
then she was like no no don't don't tell
her off just let her do whatever she's
doing
um
so thank you peter peter for working
with me it has
been a
real privilege to learn from you and to
be kind of part of this extended
academic family um okay so i'll get
started with the talk
let me just show you really quickly the
title of the talk she's bootstrapping
the error of oja's algorithm
and in hindsight when i was talking to
one of my collaborators maybe we should
have called it something like online
multiplier bootstrap for streaming pca
because that's what ojas algorithm
that that's the algorithm that i mean
that's what i'll hopefully make that
more explicit
so this is joint work with um
my collaborators robert lundy who is a
former postdoctoral scholar who is
spending a year with lisa and g at
michigan is right there so if you have
any hard questions just ask him anyways
now i'm kidding so um
so yeah and he will be joining the
um washington university at saint louis
as an assistant professor in the fall
and this is rachel ward she's a
professor in the math department at ub
austin okay um so
here's the outline of my talk i'll talk
about streaming pca
and
kind of get into distributional
approximation and
um an online bootstrap to estimate that
approximate distribution um what i also
had here is simulations and when i was
practicing i was going over so i removed
it but if i have time hopefully i'll
talk a little bit about simulations as
well okay
so let's talk about streaming pca
so here is my setup i have niid mean
zero random variables in d dimensions uh
with covariance matrix sigma and you
know this is a very uh familiar
um
objective function for pca because we
are basically saying find me a unit
vector so that when i project all my
data points on that
i'm maximizing variance that's it right
um it's a non-convex optimization
algorithm and it's like one of the very
um
nice examples of non-convex optimization
algorithms where the surface is nice so
there are no bad local optima
okay so
the thing is you can also calculate the
sample covariance matrix and look at the
principal eigenvector of that right this
is um
the thing is when d is really really
large you don't want to calculate what
if i don't want to calculate that entire
d by d matrix sample covariance matrix
so what we are going to do it is use
stochastic gradient descent okay
on that optimization objective
so if you do sgd um
it's very simple you are basically
pretending i have one data point at a
time and i'm doing a
derivative or gradient of that objective
function and i'm just moving
with some gamma t scalar that's
essentially your learning rate and
and you just keep updating your weights
this weight vector this is d dimensional
right and it's essentially eventually
going to converge to the v1 which is the
principal eigenvector of your
unknown covariance matrix
and of course because everything is
unique vector you have to do a
projection so it's like a projected sgd
algorithm
um
so the gamma t there are um
lots of different learning rate
schedules you can do
something that decays uh 1 over n and so
on and so forth
and i'll talk about that in a bit
and the initialization is very simple
you just pick a unit vector uniformly
distributed on the b dimensional sphere
see
so
this is eric yoja's algorithm he
introduced it in 1982
um
and in fact that update has roots in
something far earlier in hebei and
theory which was introduced by donald
hebb which is who is a psychologist
and in his 1949 book on organization of
behavior
um so it's some of the things like peter
was saying yesterday that you know
stochastic gradient descent is
um such a workhorse algorithm for
optimization has been there a long time
back
okay
so what i'm going to do is now kind of
get into the nitty gritties of things um
so our update if you remember was of
that form so we're going to unfold that
update okay and write down the oja
vector after i have seen n data points
what does it look like okay so and i'm
going to call that
v o j the origin direction so it looks
like something like this it's kind of
like not nice looking what's happening
is you have
a matrix product okay of n
independent matrices so it's i plus this
was my this is essentially my learning
rate i'm going to fix it at something
some like uh eta n over n a times going
to be roughly like log n okay we'll
worry about that later
um so
i have this sequence of iid matrices i'm
doing a product and then we are just
taking a projection on this
initial direction that's my numerator
that's a d by one dimensional vector
right the dimensional vector denominator
is just a norm that's what it works out
to be
okay um now why should something like
this work
um
when i looked at it was like
man
that looks complicated um so i'm going
to do something very ad hoc and handwave
we'll just look at the numerator because
if i take expectation of the whole thing
it's not nice right it's a ratio just
let's just look at the expectation of
the numerator
um
everything is nice and independent so
you basically have our identity plus
some
gamma which is eight over n sigma to the
power n so what that's doing is it's
taking your sigma and it's kind of doing
a matrix exponential okay so um
so now
the new eigenvalues of this are going to
be something like e to the power eta
times lambda i
okay so it's
what it did is if you had lambda 1 minus
lambda 2 as your gap it just increased
that gap a lot and yes i'm going to
assume that lambda 1 is not equal to
lambda for this term
um okay
uh so
and now once you have done that you
multiply by u0 it's going to very nicely
align with your principal eigenvector
direction so that's kind of what's going
on here
okay
right
so
huge amount of work on stewing pca and
noja's algorithm in computer science and
machine learning literature and
um
let me also
talk kind of give some notation here uh
sigma is our unknown covariance matrix
v1 is principal eigenvector of sigma and
lambda 1 lambda 2 are the top two
eigenvalues and we are assuming they are
separated
and the error how do we measure error so
v odja is like the oja vector which is
coming out we are going to calculate a
sine spreader okay so this is
calculating the cosine squared 1 minus
the cosine squared so if my sine square
is 0 i'm very happy because basically
saying that i have found a vector which
is sitting exactly um aligned with my
viewer
okay so
um the sharpest rate was obtained by
jane and shawn and there are many other
papers and what they show is that the
error of the offline calculation if i
just had this big matrix i calculated my
sample covariance matrix looked at the
largest eigenvector uh principal
eigenvector um
this method is going to sort of match
that okay even if i'm not getting to
look at the entire covalent matrix at a
time and i'm just looking at one data
point at a time and in particular the
sine squared error is going to be
something like 1 over n
there are caveats of course there are
conditions in particular is very strong
condition this x i x i transpose the
outer product matrix minus its
expectation which is sigma operator norm
has to be bounded on surely and you will
see this condition nearly everywhere in
all the papers on streaming pca
and there is this is essentially saying
that this is my learning rate schedule
and you can see the same the kind of
thing you've seen stochastic gradients
and something like one over t
right so okay so what are we going to do
here
so what we were interested in was saying
that okay so the sine squared error
behaves roughly like 1 over n after
seeing n data points so what we wanted
to see was if i multiplied the sine
squared error by n does that stabilize
okay so
essentially a distributional
approximation of the sine squared error
after like
uh scaling it properly and this is what
we are going to show that something like
n times the sine squared error is going
to behave like a roughly a chi-square
random variable and again i'm
not being precise here i'm just trying
to give the intuition of what's there in
the results
okay
and then how do i estimate the
distribution we are going to do an
online bootstrap sorry
um so
and in order to estimate the
distribution we'll do an online
bootstrap okay so that's kind of the two
parts of the talk yes
[Music]
so this this essentially is you are
assuming a lot of things in particular
this b is kind of i think expectation of
this thing square
so it's popping up there but you are
assuming everything is at least in the
serious literature division one of those
things are constant
and so that's why you can actually get
very strong rates like this and even if
d was exponentially n
even then this will work but
this is the
key
essentially saying that you don't really
have a high dimensional problem there is
a low dimensional problem hiding inside
um
right so let's
do that so i want to actually go to the
board here just really quickly and build
some intuition with scalars okay um
so
our matrix product was something like i
plus something times x i x i transpose
forget for a second you have vectors and
matrices let's make everything scalar
because matrices don't commute
it's not nice to move things around
let's just see what happens with scalars
okay so i'm going to write this down
oh can everyone see this
yes
and in in my case e of x i 0 e of x i
squared is sigma squared so what we are
going to do is something very simple we
say that oh you know let's write x i
squared
as sigma squared plus
x i squared minus sigma squared let's
expand this whole thing out and this is
just one i'm sorry
okay so once you do that what you get is
the first term of course the the
the first term is going to cancel out
because it's one plus sigma square over
n to the power n goes away the first
term that's left is something like a
linear an average
of
x i squared minus sigma square and then
what you have is an average of
pairwise terms and then
an average of
three trouble triples and four and so on
and um
i'm wondering if this reminds you of
anything
um
so the very fast charm of course it's
nice it's iid average of iid things
second one looks horrid but it's
uncorrelated if you take like a
if you think about just look at it
eyeball it for a second you will see
that it's sum of uncorrelated things
same for every term and they are
uncorrelated among each other right so
um
very reminiscent of the hobbing
decomposition a few statistics and the
funny thing is oops sorry um
my colleague was talking rachel was
giving a talk about
um random matrices roja somewhere and
bin was in the audience and this was far
before we were talking about this and
she asked what's the connection with
your statistics so i don't know how you
saw that
but there is this connection right so
the first term is the highest projection
right you are basically saying i have
this horrid product looking thing i'm
going to try to project it down on a
linear space of random variable sums of
functions of random variables
and this converges to a normal
distribution and the under appropriate
condition the second term
is essentially of this form and so on
and so forth and because everything is
uncorrelated they are really easy to
bump right you
the variance is very nice just
decomposes
let's now get two matrices okay so
my bn is the matrix product of that
giant thing
i can do the similar hovering
decomposition there as well and i'm
going to call those terms t0 t1 and so
on so i'm going to
i'll show you the first one t0 very easy
just expectation okay so it's like i
plus learning rate times sigma to the
power n looks like this just to
visualize it
n matrices all of them are the same
this guy right there constant
okay um
all right what about the second one
that is not very nice because now things
don't commute you have matrices right
before i could just move all the
constant things together so now what you
have is this x i x i transpose minus
sigma which is kind of like the x square
minus sigma square before in the scalar
case
what will happen is you will replace
that sequence of constant matrices you
know plug it in one two three four and
get n things and take an average of them
so ends up being something like
eta n times an average of independent
mean zero matrices okay so the structure
is very much there the analysis just
gets um
messy because things don't commute
okay so now um
so how do we put an i i also had a slide
with t2 just looks horrid because you
start putting in pairs of random
matrices different places
so
now the thing is the sine square error
can be also expressed as this okay it's
a ratio of two things and in the in the
numerator what you have is
uh u
a norm square of u b n times u zero and
what is u u is essentially the
orthogonal eigen space to v one of that
covariance matrix sigma okay so now once
we have this and this is not something
we did it's very well known and this is
how what is used for the analysis in
computer science typically in machine
learn machine learning so now the
question is um
how do i bring in what where do i go
from here so all our focus is now on the
norm of that vector this is a
d-dimensional vector norm square of that
so okay so we are basically saying the
first thing to do the most natural one
is like oh u 0 just write it in the
basis of all your d
eigenvectors right we can do that fine
linear combination of the eigenvectors
and then
you have to show
that
the norm is actually dominated by the
projection along the principal direction
that's very important because we kind of
didn't worry about any of that did some
calculations had very suboptimal rates
and we were showing rachel like our
collaborator this and she was like
that's that's very suboptimal you have
to be kind of control your errors
properly right so
so once you do that that you basically
show that the v1 direction matters
then what happens is now
you look at u n and v 1
and now you write out your v and
unfollow this holding decomposition in
there t 0 t 1 etc etc next step is to
say that everything this is actually 0
so let's not worry about that everything
else is small
so that's that's kind of what you will
have to bound and the thing the norm is
dominated by the norm of this vector and
if you look at this vector it's
essentially of this form which is
eta over n times a sum
of
vectors which are not identically
distributed but they're independent okay
so for under like
under some conditions we can still say
that this is roughly going to behave
like a normal random vector okay after i
normally scale it properly
so
so after all of that moving around and
manipulations you say that okay so my
sine squared error times n
behaves roughly like norm squared of a
normal random vector
okay and again just giving you intuition
we can make all of this formal
plus small error
so that's where our distributional
approximation is coming in
so that's theorem one i know it looks
kind of complicated but
um the thing to look at is here which is
basically saying that
the cdf of the sine squared error
properly scaled is going to behave like
the cdf of
the norm of a gaussian vector for a
suitably defined
gaussian
vector
and i don't want to get into details
here but this is essentially saying that
behave sort of like chi-square
um
there are regularity conditions on
moments of random quantities and those
are essentially i'll talk about in a
slide but
those are essentially kind of coming out
of variance decay or the fact that
i don't really have a high dimensional
problem there is some low dimensional
problem hidden into this because
otherwise i won't be able to
get rates like this
okay so
and also this learning rate is kind of
has to lie between these two
so not the learning rate like n times
the learning rate
so here are the implications the
dimensionality can grow up to e to the
power n to the power one third theorem
holds for a very large range range of
eta now previous work assumes that the
operator norm of that quantity has to be
bounded almost surely and what we say is
kind of higher moments of that quantity
it doesn't have to be bounded can grow
very slowly with respect to n okay so we
would slightly weaker but sort of the
same
um spirit is there
um
and finally if we kind of translate our
convergence result into an error bound
it matches the sharp error that
genotol had
so we didn't really lose very much up to
logarithmic factors
okay and
the proof essentially adopts a result
from zoo at all
which is a high dimensional clt for
quadratic forms and they had uh
identically distributed random variables
we have a non-identically distributed
random variable so
that's kind of where we had to do some
analysis and so on
um
okay so
this distribution approximation let's
talk about bootstrap a little bit so i
know that there is this distribution how
do i approximate it okay
um
so typically bootstrap consistency says
that i have some unknown parameter i'm
estimating using some theta hat this is
the true cdf and i'm going to
approximate it by a bootstrap cdf
condition on the data right so your
theta hat becomes theta star in
bootstrap world your theta is plug in
theta hat
now here it's slightly different from
that because um what we are saying is
the theta hat is actually the estimator
of error so this whole thing theta is
just zero so i'm i'm essentially giving
a distribution on the error itself okay
so
the goal is to show this
where
that thing just think about that as the
blue the truth is the distribution of
the sine squared error suitably scaled
and
here it's the same thing the only
difference is the v1 is the truth i
don't get to see the v1 right so i
replace it with the oja vector which is
all i have it's my estimated thing
and v star is my bootstrap replicate now
the question is how do i build my
bootstrap replicates without
calculating anything big i want to just
do online updates just like oja's
algorithm does
okay so
it's the right thing to do so now so so
the goal right now is before we
calculated one object vector you gave me
one data point i updated you gave me
another data point i updated and so on
and so forth now i'm going to maintain v
replicates which are kind of like
perturbed versions of the oja vector
along with the outer vector okay and the
question is each one of those replicates
how do i update them i update them using
online essentially multiply random
variables these are those gaussian
multipliers the right way to do the
update would be to take the expectation
out here so it's something like that
should be an identity sorry so identity
plus some learning rate times sigma
that's the expectation and whatever mean
0 stuff was left you will multiply that
by a gaussian multiplier this is kind of
the classical
way of applying multiplier random
variables to do bootstrap and you can
see the i that i essentially the
replicate so i is equal to one to b so
at any time you are kind of maintaining
a drone of these bootstrap vectors okay
thing is you know i went around like
started by saying i don't want to
calculate this estimate of the whole
sigma
right so i this is really the right
thing to do but we don't really want to
do that so what do we do
so here is a fix
and the fix is well i don't know sigma
but maybe i can
replace it i have some very noisy
estimate of it by x t x t transpose some
estimate of it and then i don't and what
do i do here well i do x t x t transpose
minus x t minus 1 x t minus 1 transpose
okay the only thing is the moment you do
x minus y of two i id random variables
you increase the variance by two so
that's why you are scaling by one over
square because that's kind of the fix
so
so this is completely online because
it's essentially online by like you are
remembering this step and the next step
so you need two data points uh the
of course there is dependence now it's
no longer
independent there is weak dependence but
as long as the norms are controlled
um this week this dependence is
manageable
and finally the bad thing is it's not
identical even the bad thing is not
about this update it's true for pretty
much any multiplier bootstrap type of
thing you
before you had this beautiful
identically distributed xtxt transposes
now you have condition on the data that
time some multiplier random variables
the id identically distributed is sort
of gone and you have to
work much harder to sort of establish
the results you did before but it's
doable okay um
right how much time do i have
so here is our online bootstrap
algorithm
i draw u0 uniformly on the dimensional
sphere i am going to keep calculating my
vector because that's what i was doing
anyway and at the same time i'm going to
maintain
b
uh bootstrap replicates each one of them
is updated updated using this
and the main quantity here is the zti
which is just
normal zero
one standard normal multiply random
value
okay so once i have that i let it finish
i've seen all my data points at the end
of it what i do is um i calculate the
sine squared error of each one of these
guys with the ojar vector i have so now
i have b sine squared error that gives
me the distribution this is kind of very
similar to what we do in
stroke um
right so and you can we can basically
show that bootstrap consistency holds as
well so under the conditions of the
theorem and there is this is very
complicated so i'm just gonna um
tell you what this is um again some
conditions on the norm the non cannot
grow of the vectors so this whole x i x
i transpose minus sigma having bounded
norm this is kind of hidden inside that
it's basically saying that on that high
probability set where things are not
growing too fast
we should again have good stuff
consistent okay
um
and
when will the norms not grow
very fast when you have some form of
variance decay there are conditions
under which you can have those things
happen
all right so
seems like i have time time for some
experiment so i'm going to show you very
basic kind of proof of concept
type of simulation results um so i'm
drawing uh some
you know d-dimensional vectors and
transforming them to have this kind of a
covariance and all you need to remember
is that this is the variance decay so if
i make my beta super large the variance
decay is very quick if i make my beta
very small it's flat to 2 4
and we essentially
do fix the initial initial u0 the
initial vector and then draw 500 data
sets run streaming pc and all of them
this is how we estimate the true cdf
because that's what we are comparing
with
and then we do the bootstrap
okay um bootstrap replicates for a given
museum
now we are gonna compare let's see
that's all i'll show you
okay so um
so here are two plots this is for beta
is equal to one there is quite a bit of
variance decay and
the red is the true sampling cdf and the
blue dots are the bootstrap cdf okay and
you can see that they are sort of close
on the left panel you have n about
um twice the number of dimensions so d
is large but not that large um
and then n is even larger so here it's
20 times d
and you can see sort of that if if i
um
give you a lot of data points this
approximation gets better and better
that's what this is showing and the next
one again is just showing where variance
decay doesn't happen doesn't work so
beta is 0.2
um the variance decays it's kind of very
flat and so what you are seeing here
again is the two curves don't match and
more than that the x-axis the values
here because i'm basically plotting the
cdf the values are really large because
things are not stabilizing you are not
converging to anything uh because that's
essentially not the regime to be looking
at um
but if i again give you lots and lots
and lots of data points you'll start
working there so
yep so that's it so here in summary um
there are lots of open questions here um
we did something
um
for
oja's algorithm oja type updates show up
in a lot of machine learning algorithms
so like you know many non-convex
problems like matrix completion subspace
tracking and so on and so forth and one
interesting thing would be to does these
methods or ideas do they transfer to
those non-convex optimization algorithms
as well can i do bootstrap there can i
have a distribution of
similar sort of error
we need iid random variables what
happens for
um
weekly dependent streams of data so
say markovian data or just weak
we tweak dependence
and also
top k principle vectors i'm showing you
something really simple just the top
eigenvector
um what if i wanted to go to top k
principle subspace what happens there so
these are all things we are thinking
about and yeah i'm gonna
[Music]
open for questions
[Applause]
pretty nice work so one question if you
really truly want to be uh streaming
then your step size cannot depend on n
that's right thank you so much so what
the thing is if you make it one over t
then some of the conditions of clt
doesn't work because weighting different
data points differently so what we were
thinking about doing was sort of doing
it in batches
so you know you kind of guess an end you
go with that end and then once you
increase you
exceed that you double it and you keep
going and so on so that that's the
chi-square did you try the chi-square
approximation does it work well
the chi-square approximation has
so many you need to
you know actually the the the right
thing to say is that i didn't because it
had all these model parameters that you
need to know like sigma different
um properties of sigma moments of it so
i i didn't do that but
so the chi squared parameters depends on
all the other things yeah yeah it
depends on all the model parameters like
sigma and so on and and it's higher
moments x i transfer minus sigma's
higher momentum
right thank you
oh yeah it scaled chi squared yes yes
okay i just wondered about the uh
bootstrap algorithm uh in formula three
i mean you need to replace the sigma by
an estimate right and why don't i mean
why not taking from one to t minus one
and only the last one you know in
formula three on the right
three yeah you have x t minus one x t
minus one transpose right so this is a
very noisy estimate of sigma right why
not going back to say x one t minus one
one t minus one transposed
um i just thought okay i mean of course
i see what's going on here i mean
roughly but i would have taken a bit
more information into account so you are
you are thinking that maybe instead of
this take an average over the trouble is
uh you are so okay so that's a great
question it's a great question because
it lets me get into this a little more
so if you look at this i never calculate
my x dxt transpose which is d by d right
so i'm always calculating some sort of a
projection and so on so
if i keep averaging over t
um okay sorry let me let me um
change that so i don't i think your
scheme i don't really need to calculate
a d by d thing right i can still do like
an online updated thing just by looking
at t minus one
it will be more um
accurate but it will make the dependence
much more yeah that i understand but i
mean there may be a trade-off to go back
yeah we will try that that's a great
question we didn't we just went with one
and age four but thank you for that yeah
thanks warner for a great talk um
so
peter asked the the first of my two
questions um
you you mentioned
use statistics and you mentioned hydric
projection and huffman decomposition and
so i was expecting the next thing to be
some kind of a degeneracy or
non-degeneracy
condition and it never showed up is that
because
you're already kind of looking at second
moments and
[Music]
like i expected there to be some
condition that says that the you know
the the tucked and decomposition that
leading order term dominates that
usually requires something like
non-degeneracy with respect to that's a
great question let me go back to that
theorem really quickly
thanks
so
i
hit a lot of things here one of the
things was something like you will need
a lower bound on the variance
right so that's your non-degeneracy
condition right there and that's sort of
yeah i sometimes do this of like trying
to make it more accessible and i hide
things that i shouldn't hide sorry about
that but no no need to be sorry are you
curious thanks so much
the first principal component is easier
your comments at the valley end how
about the second one any thought
um so
so the the whole
the analysis of oja
um
it works for top k right so so all of
these things no i don't know about the
distribution approximation but most of
the theory works for top k as long as
there is a gap it works like you know
gap between maybe two and three if there
is a large gap then two should work so
um that's my feeling that if there is a
gap it should be extendable but yeah i
i'm thinking about it i haven't really
worked it out
it's a quick question so is it possible
to put a factor of lambda 2
on the numerator on the left side
because we know if lambda 2 is 0 the
problem is trivial
right i mean yeah that's um
my on my feeling is that maybe there was
a lambda i'll have to go check but it's
quite likely that we just abstracted it
out because it's a constant but i'll go
check because that's a great point yeah
yeah thank you
any other questions
not let's thank our speaker wonderful
presentation
you now have a coffee break think
outside again